this segment is going to be very
depressing to many people in the
audience and I do apologize for that but
it has to be reported because it's so
troubling and atrocious the president
still doesn't understand viruses at some
general level remember that early in the
entire corona virus pandemic we learned
from Trump's statements that he doesn't
really understand vaccines there were
signs that he didn't really understand
the concept of virus versus bacteria he
didn't understand the concept of
contagion or a viral spread or
exponential growth or herd immunity or
the concept of per capita or any of it
but by now we would at least hope that
he sort of understands the concept of a
virus but he still doesn't this is a
clip from his press briefing on Friday
now after we listen to it and watch it
we'll put up a transcript of it on the
screen because it is actually so
weaponized that you need to see it in
writing to fully grasp it here is Trump
talking about the germ is a genius and
it has figured out how not to be hurt by
antibiotics which of course antibiotics
are for bacteria not for viruses take a
look at this brilliant enemy they
develop drugs like the antibiotics you
see it antibiotics used to solve every
problem now one of the biggest problems
the world has is the germ has gotten so
brilliant that the antibiotic can't keep
up with it and they're constantly trying
to come up with a new people go to a
hospital and they catch they go for a
heart operation that's no problem but
they end up dying from from problems you
know the problems I'm talking about
there's a whole genius to it we're
fighting not only is it hidden but it's
very smart ok it's invisible and it's
hidden but it's it's very smart and you
see that in a case like a denver but you
know i think we're doing well and and
there on denver antibiotics used to
solve every problem he says until the
germ got brilliant and now can avoid it
except of course corona virus is a virus
you don't
treat a virus with antibiotics now let's
look at some of this in writing because
it's actually really really crazy look
at what Donald Trump says this is a very
brilliant enemy you know it's a
brilliant enemy they develop drugs like
antibiotics you see it antibiotics used
to solve every problem now one of the
biggest problems the world has is the
germ has gotten so brilliant that the
antibiotic can't keep up with it and
they're constantly trying to come up
with a new people go to a hospital and
they catch they go for a heart operation
that's no problem but they end up dying
from from problems you know the problems
I'm talking about there's a whole genius
to it
we're fighting not only is it hidden but
it's very smart okay it's invisible and
it's hidden but it's it's very smart and
you see that in a case like Denver now
there are some defenders of Trump that
are arguing Trump is actually very
astutely talking about the problem of
antibiotic resistance is there any
evidence that suggests Trump ant
understands antibiotic resistance maybe
what Trump meant is that the genius of
the germ is that it chose to be a virus
instead of a bacteria so that
antibiotics wouldn't work against it is
that something he has the nuclear codes
folks he has nuclear launch codes and he
thinks a virus is a genius and that it's
not affected by antibiotics as part of
that genius this reminds me of what
might be Donald Trump's other big crazy
unintelligible rant about Uncle John
Trump and nuclear weapons there are many
highlights or lowlights but the genius
germ rant reminded me of the Uncle John
Trump rant which was this one remember
it know what wrecks me look having
nuclear my uncle was a great professor
and scientist and engineer dr. John
Trump at MIT good good genes very good
genes okay very smart the Wharton School
of Finance very good very smart you know
if you're a conservative Republican if I
were a liberal if like okay if I ran as
a Liberal Democrat they would say I'm
one of the smartest people ever in the
world
screw but when you're a conservative
Republican they try do they do a number
that's why I always sort of went to
Wharton was a good student went there
went there did this built the four yet i
have to give my like credentials all the
time because we're a little
disadvantaged but you look at the
nuclear deal the thing that really
bothers me it would have been so easy
and it's not as important as these lives
are nuclear is so powerful
my uncle explained that to me many many
years ago the power and that was 35
years ago he would explain the power of
what's going to happen and he was right
who would have thought but when you look
at what's going on with the four
prisoners now used to be three now it's
four but when it was three and even now
i would have said it's all in the
messenger fellas and its fellas because
you know they don't they haven't figured
that the women are smarter right now
than the men so not only is that insane
to the degree that it rivals Trump's
more recent genius germ rant note also
how much more articulate Trump is in
that segment from just a few years ago
the decline in Trump's speech capacity
becomes even more clear when you look
even just a few years ago never mind ten
or fifteen years ago we are really truly
acutely screwed here guys one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep and it's a
sponsor I'm thrilled about because I
sleep on a helix mattress at home and
it's just the perfect mattress one of
the best things about helix is you don't
have to guess which mattress do I need
which one will be good for me you take
their famous sleep quiz on their website
you tell them your body type your
sleeping position your back pain issues
you might have and they will pair you
with a mattress that will be perfect for
you I took the sleep quiz the mattress
they suggested was exactly what I needed
I often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool it's not too soft
it's not too firm the texture is right
and I've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress every
decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all he
feliks mattresses come with a 10 year
warranty and they'll even come to your
house and pick it up within a hundred
days if you don't love it but I think
you will all of my viewers will get up
to $200 off your order and you'll get to
super premium pillows for free when you
go to the link right underneath this
video